los pandora papers ponen de nuevo la
lupa sobre la industria de paraísos
fiscales y sociedades offshore una red
de fideicomisos opacos de empresas de
papel y élites mundiales cómo se crean
estas entidades primero es un destino
distinto al de la residencia de su
beneficiario france24 habló con ewald
scharfenberg periodista venezolano y
miembro de la investigación y eso
sociedades que buscan esos destinos
a conseguir en jurisdicciones donde la
supervisión del estado o la carga
tributaria es muy baja y eso permite
justamente
evitar el pago de impuestos o sobre todo
ocultar fondos que tienen digamos
orígenes oscuros si bien su creación es
legal el problema surge cuando estas
sociedades se esconden en jurisdicciones
opacas sin declarar a las autoridades
del país donde el propietario tiene su
residencia fiscal real y así no pagar
impuestos estas mismas mismas refugios
tributarios como hay también coinciden
con muy pocos requisitos para de control
por parte del estado
normalmente son utilizados para quienes
financian actividades ilícitas o quienes
tienen dinero proveniente de la
corrupción o que por ejemplo están
financiando el terrorismo suelen
utilizar también esas vías américa
latina pierde más de 40 mil millones de
dólares en impuestos cada año debido a
estas estructuras
además los pandora papers revelan cómo
gran parte de la élite política mundial
independientemente de sus signos
políticos está implicada esta clase
política que es la que debería ponerle
coto a estas prácticas
bufetes y bancos internacionales en
impuestos o prácticas rutinarias en el
mundo financiero internacional pues
dejaría no pueden poner de costos porque
también son parte interesada pues tras
la magnitud de estas investigaciones una
de las dudas que quedan en el aire es
cuáles pueden ser las consecuencias
jurídicas de los involucrados